katie oprah's interview has now been
viewed in the uk
what is the reaction there well the
reaction has been one of
astonishment really we had of course
woken up to
headlines based on what you'd seen in
the us but it was only last night that
people actually got to see the
interview in full now interestingly some
saw it as so offensive to the queen that
they actually turned off
after the first hour itv saw a number of
viewers
check out after an hour i mean that may
also be because it was screened quite
late in the uk but
we know that this has created a real
backlash over here
the papers today are full of commentary
articles commentators basically saying
this is harry detonating his family that
really
is the feeling over here how is the
difference
between what u.s viewers thought and
what uk viewers thought
for the most part u.s viewers seem to
back megan and harry meanwhile in the uk
it seems from the polls that we've seen
most people back the monarchy why is
that in america
it was a clear case of team sussex in
terms of who came out
on top i think over here there is a
feeling that
the monarchy has been largely
disrespected by the couple
they feel that the timing of this
interview was very wrong
and that by detonating those bombs
particularly
that suggestion of racism in those
months when i was
pregnant all around this same time
so we have in tandem the conversation of
he won't be
given security he's not going to be
given a title
and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
what who do people believe made that
statement i mean
just generally what is the consensus of
who that statement could have come from
i think
because of the severity of the
allegations everyone's being very
careful in terms of
naming who it might have been we know
it's not the queen or the duke of
edinburgh because oprah clarified that
i mean senior members of the royal
family are few and far between
it's going to either be prince charles
prince william
or camilla and the inference of course
of it being one of those high-profile
senior members of the royal family
is the question is racism at the heart
of the british monarchy
in the aftermath of this prince charles
was asked about
this interview while he was out and he
did not
bat an eye what do you make of that well
i think the message from
the royal family is today is the
business day as usual we know that their
aids have been locked in crisis meetings
we understand that there may be a
statement possibly later on today
the prince of wales was out on
engagements today sending off a very
clear signal
it's business of usual of course
somebody asked the question about the
interview
and the royals have a deft hand at
avoiding or pretending they can't hear
these questions and
charles moves swiftly on he's clearly
not going to be drawn on this while he
is on an official engagement if
and when the royals do say something i
think it will be a collective statement
out of buckingham palace kensington
palace and clarence house
and i think probably the reason it's
taking some time is because they want to
make sure
they get it right there were reports
that a statement was ready to go on
monday night
before the show aired over here and that
the queen said let's just hold
this statement a lot of people wondering
if that's because she actually wanted to
watch the program
herself when it went out live in america
her aides watched the program and
briefed her the next morning over what
must have been a very awkward
breakfast meeting it is possible that
the queen wanted to sit down and watch
this
for herself but we do understand that it
was the queen
who pressed the pause button on issuing
that statement last night
do you think they know who made that
statement internally
inside the palace do they know who uh
harry was referencing or
do you think they're as baffled as the
rest of the world well i think if this
was a
conversation or conversations between
harry and a member of the royal family i
would imagine that within the family
absolutely it's known who it was that
made those comments
what do you think happens if that
person's name is leaked or that person's
name is or that person is identified
well the problem with all of this
speculation and names being banded
around is that it does cause a huge
amount of damage
suggestions that it might be prince of
wales and that that is why
he and harry have fallen out and harry
has said he feels let down by his father
are very damaging
to the prince of wales's reputation and
you know ditto prince william who's done
a huge amount
to help combat racism in sports
particularly on the football pitch
and who's who's really backing these
anti-racist campaigns over here
in britain so by associating
charles and william with these racist
comments which are alleged to have been
made
to harry it's very damaging for the work
that the royal family is trying to do at
the moment
particularly prince william who's really
been invested
in wiping out racism in british football
he has said
there's no place for racism in this
country what are your sources telling
you about this
meeting this summit of the big three
well it was almost impossible to get
hold of anyone
at any of the households yesterday it
really was a case of lockdown i think
crisis meetings have been going on ever
since the program
aired in the united states i do know
that courteous while they were braced
for
for something explosive they totally
underestimated
just how far harry and megan would go
the talk of the palace is that they
are absolutely horrified by what has
been said they feel that
harry has literally thrown the family
under a bus
the allegations came thick and fast and
i think they
took everyone by surprise what do you
think is going to happen now that kate
and
william have an engagement coming up on
thursday will they
answer questions or will they just do
the as you said
turn a deaf air royal style well the
cambridges have an engagement coming up
on thursday
i think this was always going to be
quite a busy week for the royals the
royals knew there was going to be a
fallout from this interview i don't
think they realized quite how serious
the fallout would be
but this was always due to be a busy
week in the royal calendar and i think
we will see the cambridges absolutely
commit to those engagements in their
diaries they won't want to let anyone
down
but they certainly won't be commenting
on this um in any capacity or an
official engagement
if and when word comes i think it will
come as a joint
statement from all three households
do they need to do something more than
just a joint statement because this is
so damaging and because so many
accusations have been hurled at them
well i think the royal family will be
hoping that people will
judge them the firm the institution
on its work and i think if you look at
the work the queen has done
around the commonwealth which is so
multicultural and so multi-racial
that work speaks for itself prince
william and his work in
trying to stamp out racism in the
british sporting world
again speaks for itself so yes i think
there are calls for a statement but
i do think that the family will be
hoping that people will
will see from what the royals do i think
the royals are hoping that
people will see and understand that
their feeling very much is that there is
no place
for racism in britain one of the
criticisms that the couple is getting
is they requested privacy and yet moved
to the u.s and are taking projects
that keep them in the public eye what do
you think of that i think the issue of
privacy was always going to be something
that was going to come back
and haunt the sussexes i mean don't
forget
that this interview came off the back of
them winning a very high profile
copyright and privacy battle
against the mail on sunday newspaper and
yet here we have a
couple who are fiercely protective of
their private lives they certainly were
over here in the uk sitting down and
giving
not one but two very intimate very
personal interviews and a lot of people
are saying
well how can you ask for privacy
when you're opening up about your
private life it is why the queen
has never given an interview herself she
firmly believes
that once you start talking about your
private life it's impossible to go back
pandora's box has been opened you can't
just put the lid back on
and i think harry and megan may find
themselves in a situation
that if and when they have another
privacy battle on their hands
they may not find that it's in their
favor this time round
because they have been so open about
their private lives
do you think also that maybe the queen
or charles or one of them will break
their silence because of this interview
or will it be business as you they'll
never break their silence
there is clearly a lot of pressure on
the royal family to break their silence
the age-old mantra which has kept the
queen in good stead all of these years
has been
never complain never explained but i
think such is the severity
of these allegations the reverberations
of which are being felt
not just here in britain and across the
pond in the states but around the world
are so serious that there really is a
lot of pressure
for a statement to be released from
buckingham palace with some sort of an
explanation
we do know that crisis talks have been
taking place at the palace ever since
the oprah interview was aired in the
united states i think it has been a case
of lockdown at the palace it's been
almost impossible
to get hold of aids palace spokespeople
and that is because they are working out
the best way to respond i think
if and when it comes it will be a
statement from
all households they will want to show
unity that they are
under huge pressure to give some
explanation
some response to those incredibly
damaging revelations
that there is racism at the heart of the
monarchy i do know
that the queen was at windsor and that
william was back
in london along with charles did they
get on the phone or did they meet in
person
well there have been reports that there
has been a meeting between
charles the queen and prince william and
they are actually in separate parts of
the country but of course the queen is
now very favored soon
and so one imagines that if they've been
speaking it is either over a video
conference call or perhaps on the phone
what does a meeting look like with
charles and the queen and william what's
it like when they get together to talk
are there aids around or is it just the
three of them because our only reference
is really like the crown
i think if you were to use the
sandringham summit earlier this year
where the future of the sussexes was
discussed
that's probably a pretty good template
for what one of these
family crisis meetings looks like of
course that was pre-lockdown they could
meet in person
but they are they are very small it is a
very
um select audience that gets to be a
part of that discussion
and that really is the principles the
queen prince charles and prince william
and their private secretaries and it is
kept as tight as possible for very
obvious reasons
they don't want any leaks